[Music]
who's there
you thought you defeated to be here but
I have returned stronger than ever to
series no it is I cinnamon toast can you
deleted my system32 you bastard I
challenge you the world's most dangerous
game but Ken that was three years ago
what I've been gone for three years
nanny will find Ken I accept your
challenge
boohoo I'm still mad about losing a
video game three years ago
it was more than that it was everything
all my memes lost forever ah well well
well I don't care little [ __ ] you I
challenge you to a game of
rock-paper-scissors oh well I'll have
you know I am the winning champion of
rock-paper-scissors undefeated how could
I forget
yeah you forgot that in you in three
years three long is you forgot for three
years now you will pay again Ken the
rules are the same whoever wins in
rock-paper-scissors best out of three
gets to control the other person's
computer for 34 seconds someone need
good clotting in the South the whole
time oh here we go round one
what should I pick maybe I'll go for
scissor oh I know all your moves oh
you've made your choice huh
ah you made a grave mistake challenging
okay I'm still shook right now good
maybe I'll go sister again you did
well its first two three so it doesn't
even matter
[Music]
are you scared kin shaking right now
maybe I'll go see sir again getting
triggered damn it come on come on guy
please
Caesar come on it's time come to
activate come on my trump card no not
the trunk for three years you can do it
will be defeated it will not be defeated
by the likes of your kind
say goodbye to your Twitter no please
not my Twitter my James it's time for me
to hack your system oh I'm inside your
computer can no oh man look at but this
is can you have a wife dr. Phil without
a mustache no I'm sorry for this my time
is running out I have to be doing good
he's got what is this no look please
please please no no thank you know a
from me okay I lost access Jesus Christ
the most dangerous game when he put it
all on the line good well well well can
bombs or Fergana what you didn't know
can is that I can't just hack your
computer
I can also hack your mind
I know exactly what you're picking
you've know told ya you'll never expect
this choice though really will I
unbelievable I did that on purpose but
you will never get it twice last prayer
can and this time your stupid memes
won't distract me hmm important is my
moussaka too easy you've been down okay
and the Cerebral Assassin I'm in Baba
just wait I'm not showing you my true
power
oh really we'll see about that I'm
hacking into your computer
what are you looking at over here what
is this Oh would be shame if you oh now
there's a real opportunity hm hey oh you
are subscribe now your bail notification
suit you thought I was done
[Music]
get out no damn it
now even worse even worse than having my
system32 deleted round three well he's
made his choice
oh god he's too strong how could I
possibly make a choice how could I
possibly make a choice it's impossible
please the Internet look alright
think you're up for the challenge we're
just getting started
I knew what else I knew what I signed up
for yeah
you will never guess what happens yeah
ha ha
you will never guess you will never
[Laughter]
never ha time to hack again well well
well what do we have here I didn't say
that I didn't see that no please don't
know it takes so long it goes down
[Laughter]
alright can it's been a tough battle but
this is it I'm giving you one last
chance it's time for me to activate my
stand uh uh how does he know about the
stand no one can withstand oh no not
this hour
first-first why let them know no the
only way for me to defeat t-series no no
no whoa what is it can you waste
ha ha ha sometime you only have 15
seconds left
all right ha I must see just how much
money does this YouTube channel make no
me
what cheaper simulators becoming
relevant no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes this game is still relevant god damn
it